All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics. First
of all, please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have questions, you can unmute
and ask questions or use chatroom to post
your questions so that we can address them
in q&a session at the end of today's DDPS
seminar is open to external audiences.
So no class wide discussion. Finally,
the talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel. That's about it. Now,
let me briefly introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Dr. Elmas. With Xi'an,
who is a postdoctoral fellow at the Department of
Aerospace Engineering at University of Michigan.
She received her PhD in mechanical engineering
from Kansas State University in 2020. With her
dissertation focused on stabilization of
projects and basically the student models
for real time prediction of dynamics in strongly
nonlinear compressible flow obligations. During
her postdoctoral experience at the University
of Michigan, she has been working with Professor
Karthik, Euro Sami at the computational
neuroscience lab on surrogate modeling and
non intrusive modal reduction in complex systems
using system identification and machine learning.
Today elnaz will present an exciting topic, which
is data driven, balancing trans transformations
for predictive model order reduction. I'm
sure we will hear an exciting talk today.
But before I pass the baton, let me ask a couple
of questions to Elena's so that we get to know her
better and make this seminar somewhat informal.
It's okay here the question goes. Obviously,
you are passionate about data driven modeling
in general, is there any moment in your life
when you realize that? Wow, this is it? This
is the field I would like to commit my career.
Well, first of all, thank you so much for
the introduction, Dr. Chou. And regarding
the question, I should say that, yes, I guess,
when I realized the vast application of model
reduction in many query applications, and how
these methods can accelerate applications,
like uncertainty quantification, and design
optimization, I was really amazed by that.
And I thought that this, this should
be the topic that I should pursue in my
future career. Awesome. Awesome.
Okay, the floor is yours.
Okay, thank you so much. I'm very glad to have
the opportunity to be here in this seminar today,
and talk about our studies on balanced truncation.
So first and foremost, let me introduce the
airport Center of Excellence on multi fidelity
modeling of rocket combustion dynamics, which is a
collaboration between five different universities
on advancement of model reduction methods for
complex systems. And what I'm going to talk about
in today's presentation is mainly part of our
studies on model reduction in linear systems. They
have been amazing developments in this group on
other topics as well under this project, including
basis adaptation operator inference methods and
neural network based roms that you can check
out here if you're interested. And with that,
let's get started. So, as you know, reduced order
modeling techniques are have emerged to substitute
their high fidelity simulations in many career
applications, in which we need to repetitively
compute the qualities of interest for 10s of
1000s of times. And so using the high fidelity
simulations, some at least millions of degrees of
freedom in these applications will be infeasible.
Mother reduction methods fall under two
categories. intrusive and non intrusive, intrusive
intrusive methods need access to the governing
equations and non intrusive methods mainly rely on
data, and they don't need access to the governing
equations. And now if you're familiar with model
reduction, you know that sorry, projection based
model reduction methods are being applied to
problems of increasing increasing complexity these
days, such as the examples that I've shown in
these pictures. And this is enabled only by making
major improvements in that standard projection
based model reduction and framework so Let's first
take a very quick look at the standard process for
projection based ROMs. In which let's consider
this set of generic equations as our heart
hyperreality model, what we do is that we first
use data to compute a low dimensional to obtain
a low dimensional space using a dimensionality
reduction method. For example, proper orthogonal
decomposition is a popular choice. And so let's
say there are purely modes, they're also called
that trial subspace here are represented by
matrix V. And then we use a test subspace W to
project their governing equations onto their lower
dimensional space. In Galerkin projection that has
centralized subspaces are the same. Now, there
are certain limitations in the standard process,
and specifically periodic working procedure that
prevents application of the standard process
to complex problems like this. What are the
limitations is that pod is a linear dimensionality
reduction method. So if you're if you're dealing
with strongly nonlinear problems, then we're gonna
need a lot of modes to capture the true dynamics
and that defeats the purpose of model reduction.
And on the other hand, pod is biased towards
the most energetic modes. So, for example,
in control applications, we are mainly interested
in the most control about modes rather than the
most energetic modes. So, pod is only suitable for
these applications. If the most controllable modes
are also the most energetic modes, we have similar
issues with observability as well. For example,
if you're interested in capturing acoustic modes
that do not contain a lot of energy, then these
modes these features will be these waves will be
truncated through the standard pod process. And
another limitation with the standard political
working procedure is that if the Jacobian matrix
of the high fidelity model is not symmetric,
which is the case in many complex applications,
the Galerkin method does not necessarily preserve
stability through model reduction. Now, there have
been many methods that are developed in their past
years to address these limitations in the standard
projection based model reduction methods and I
believe these methods fall under these categories
that I have mentioned here. The first thing
that we can do is to move away from the linear
dimensionality method and use a nonlinear manifold
that is, that could be for example, constructed by
auto encoder neural networks or to adapt the pod
basis in time to get a piecewise linear subspace.
And other set of methods are developed to promote
symmetry in ROM equations. So that's stable
stability is preserved through model reduction. We
also have run stabilization techniques and closure
modeling, that basically improve the reduced
order models by modifying their arm equations
and also hyper reduction which is outside of
the scope of this talk. Now for specifically
for linear systems, balanced truncation developed
by marine 1981 is also a projection based model
reduction method that addresses the limitations
of the standard pod Galerkin projection, mainly
by taking the first two approaches here. So let's
consider a linear time invariant system as shown
here imbalanced truncation, we are still looking
for a hierarchical model representation. But the
definition of hierarchy imbalance, Truncation is
different from purely so unbalanced truncation.
Instead of ordering the most from the most
energetic to the least energetic, we would
like as we do in a pod, we would like to order the
most from the most controllable and observable to
the least controllable and observable. And in the
next, I guess, 50 minutes, we'll see how we can
do that. So first things first, I'll go through
some basic system theoretic topics that we need
to understand unbalanced truncation and its data
driven version eigen system realization algorithm.
And then we'll talk about so for example, external
description, internal description and system
realization are the foundations for the August
system realization algorithm, and reachability and
observability and system grammarians are required
to understand the balance truncation. And after
talking about these algorithms, we'll see the
results of applying against the symbolization
algorithm to two numerical experiments a one
dimensional reacting to a problem and then
aeroacoustic prediction problem and here I will
also further introduce some additional methods to
reduce the offline cost of construction Abrahms by
era era. So now what is the external description?
There are two ways to describe a system external
description and internal description. External
description of a system is mainly concerned with
its input output behavior. So let's consider a
system to be like a black box. When we look at
this black box From outside, the only things
that we can see are the input signal that we
are applying to the system. And as we generated
by the system in response to that input,
which is probably measured by some sensors,
and this is what happens in many real world
applications in which we don't have access to
the governing equations, and we don't know what's
going on inside this black black box. So external
description is basically the mapping S from the
inputs u to the outputs y. And for discrete time
system, it's given by this equation here that
takes this shape in matrix form. And this matrix
in the middle of that slide is actually a
weighting matrix that identifies how the
outputs depends on the inputs at different time
steps. Now, we want to see how we can obtain this
mapping, and also whether we can use this mapping
and the external description to understand what's
going on inside this black box. And of course,
the answer is yes. So, our linear time invariant
system, the each row in that weighting matrix
in the external description can be described by
a sequence of constant matrices this sequence is
also called the sequence sub Markov parameters.
So for linear time invariant and causal system and
by causal we mean the output at the current time
step depends on the inputs at the current time the
past time steps and not the future time steps. So,
for a system under these conditions, this sequence
of Markov parameters is given by the response of
the system to unit impulse. So it can be obtained
in a data driven manner. And each of these blocks
in this sequence are p by n matrices, where p
is the number of outputs and m is the number
of inputs. So under these conditions, the
impulse response snapshots of the system
basically identify their input output behavior
or the external description of their system.
Now, as I mentioned, another way to describe the
system is through the internal description, this
is also called state space representation, which
may be more familiar to you. And for discrete time
system, the internal description is given by a set
of difference equations as shown here, which has
this exact solution at the bottom of the slide.
And so here, the system is no longer a black box.
So this besides their inputs and outputs, we also
have information about the state and the governing
equations. And this is the output equation here
with where c is the output map that identifies
the how the system interacts with the surroundings
and use that fifth term in the exact solution here
x k zero is the initial condition. And here b is
the input map and A is the dynamics matrix. And of
course, if the system matrices are constant with
respect to time, we have a linear time invariant
system. Now, we can use this exact solution of
the state space representation to show that this
equation at the bottom of the slide is actually
that impulse response of the system. Now, why do I
mention this here? The reason is that later when I
when I explain eigen system realization algorithm,
I will refer to this expression here as the
impulse response or the sequence of Markov
parameters. And I'd like to to you to see why this
is their sequence of Markov parameters. So simply
substitute a unit impulse for you in the exact
solution and substitute x in the output equation,
and you'll get the impulse response of the
system at each time step. Now, as I mentioned,
the sequence of Markov parameters for a linear
time invariant system is given by the impulse
response. So if you're convinced that this is
the impulse response of the system, then we can
go ahead and use this expression to obtain each of
them Markov parameters in this sequence in terms
of their system matrices. So for example, at the
first time said k equals zero and the first block
would be D. Then at the second time, step k was
one, the second block would be ECB, and so on so
forth. Now, I'd like to mention here that the
system transfer function which is actually the
Laplace transform of the impulse response of the
system, and of course, the markup parameters are
invariant under coordinate transformation, which
means that later imbalanced truncation when we
transform the system to another coordinates,
these quantities remain unchanged. Now system,
the system realization theory is the foundation
for the data driven version of balanced truncation
that we are mainly focused on in this work. And
as I mentioned in many enduring applications,
we do not have access to the governing equations
or we do have access to equations, but we want
to build a lower dimensional representation
for the system. And a system realization uses
the external description or the input output
behavior of the system to build the internal
description or the state space representation. So
again, let's say the system is like a black box.
And the only information that we have is about
the inputs and sensor measurements, we want to
know if we can use that information to identify
the governing equations. Now, there are multiple
ways to do this. But we are here specifically
focused on on taking a system theoretic approach
that resembles close connections with balance
truncation that comes with stability guarantees.
So the problem is to is that given the external
description from simulations and experiments,
we want to identify the internal description.
And I'd also like to mention here that there
are infinitely many realizations for a system.
But we are interested, and these realizations
will give us the same output for a specific input.
But we are interested in the realization that can
do this task with the minimum number of degrees of
freedom. And that's called the minimum realization
and the eigen system realization algorithm is a
way to construct this minimum realization. So,
the Eigen system realization algorithm mainly
relies on a matrix that is called Hankel matrix.
This matrix that's shown here is assemble a
matrix by with the impulse response or the
sequence of Markov parameters as its rows, then
this matrix is called the hanging Hankel matrix.
And it's plays a key role in model reduction
of linear systems as we will see. So only two
topics are left here there is stability and
observability and also the system grimy hands
before we can talk about Balanced truncation. And
what is reachability? Yeah, what is reliability a
system is reachable if all of these states can be
excited by the control action or in other words,
if the impact of the control signal can reach all
of the states in the system, then that system is
reachable. And for a linear time invariant
system reachability reduces to an algebraic
definition that's basically identified by this
matrix here, which is called the reachability
matrix and LTI system is reachable if and only
if the rank of this matrix is equal to the order
of the system. And, and observability, on the
other hand, determines whether the all of the
states in the system are accessible through the
outputs. For example, if the output of the system
remains unchanged, and with respect to variations
in one of these state variables, then the system
is not observable. And also observability is
identified by this matrix that's shown here, which
is the observability matrix. And how the system is
observable if and only if this matrix is full rank
small n here, or is the size of the state.
Yes, and n is the size of that
state its degrees of freedom.
Okay. Thank you. Sure.
So now we can go ahead and define the system
Grammy is for a stable continuous time
system and the reachability grammarian is as shown
by this equation, and it's actually the solution
of this layup equation. For discrete time systems,
this reachability grammarian can be computed using
the reachability matrix. And the system gram Ian's
are Hermitian matrix matrices and they have real
Eigen values, which means that if we apply Eigen
value decomposition to the reachability gram,
Ian its largest Eigen values correspond to the
directions that are the most reachable in the
system or the states that can be affected by
the smallest amount of actuation energy. Now,
keep that in mind, I'll come back to this
point in a few seconds. Similarly, for a
stable continuous time system that observability
grammarian is given by this equation and it's
the solution to another the opponent equation
and for discrete time systems, this Crimean
can be computed using the observability
matrix. The observability granion is also
a Hermitian matrix and its largest Eigen values
correspond to the most observable directions
and now remember that at the beginning of the
talk, I mentioned that in balance truncation,
we are looking for modal representation that
basically orders the modes from that most
comfortable about and most observable to the least
controllable and observable. The system grammars
the reachability and observability. Grandmas
identifies how reachable and observable each state
in the system is. And therefore we can directly
use these grammars to identify That's more than
representation for balance truncation and other
points here is that instead of solving these
the operative equations to obtain their system
grammarians, we can also obtain these granules by
a by a data driven approach. So, the reachability
graph can can be computed by the impulse response
of the direct system and the observability grania
and can be computed by the impulse response of the
joint system and these are called the empirical
grandmas. Okay, so, I guess that we've covered
all the theory that we needed to lay the
foundation for balance truncation and eigen
system realization algorithm. And at this point,
we can jump into these exciting topics. So, for an
LTI system that's shown here, which represents
our high fidelity model, imbalance truncation,
we are looking for a transformation matrix T
that makes the reachability and observability.
grammarians equal and diagonal or in other words
balanced. So WEP is here, the reachability Damion,
who is the observability, grammarian, and sigma
is that is a diagonal matrix. Now, why do we want
to balance the ground? Yes, the reason is that we
want to give equal weight to the controllability
and observability such that the states that are
difficult to reach are also difficult to observe.
And we can get rid of them because these states
need a lot of activation energy to be affected.
And even if they are affected, the output of
the system is barely sensitive with respect
to their variation. So we can just remove those
states from the system. And so as I mentioned,
the reachability unobservable to gram yawns are
the key components of balance truncation. So the
first thing that we do here is to compute
these grammarians by solving the opponent
of equations. And right up front, you can see
that this method can only be applied to stable
systems because these granules are only defined
for a stable system. They're not defined for
unstable systems. And so in order to compute the
transformation matrix that balances the Grampians,
we compute the Cholesky factors of the gram
years, and then SVD of the product product of
the two, let's get factors. And from there, we
can compute the balancing modes and the inverse
balancing modes that are at the end used
along with the full order model matrices A,
B, and C to construct their own matrices. So the
transformation matrix T is actually a matrix that
transforms that system to coordinates in which the
most control but most are also the most observable
modes. And in this stage, where we can't be
SVD of the product of the two Alaskey factors,
we actually try and create the singular vectors
corresponding to the smallest singular values,
because the singular vectors represent the least
controllable and the least observable directions.
And as you can see, in order to compute the raw
matrices, we are directly using the order model
matrices, so the method is intrusive. For balance
truncation, we need to have access to the raw
matrices. Powerful aspects of balanced rams is
that they satisfy these error bounds that I've
shown here, where g is the transfer function of
order model, and gr is the transfer function of
the room. So that rom error is upper bounded by
the sum of the truncated singular values. Now,
although balanced drums satisfy theoretical
error bounds, but there are certain limitations
that prevent their application to more complex
problems. We've already talked about some of these
limitations. And at the bottom here, I have some
methods that address each of these limitations
and challenges. And in their eyes, I have a list
of a few sample references that you can look at
if you're interested in any of these scenarios.
Like for example, if the system is unstable, if
there are a few unstable nodes in the system that
you want to preserve through model reduction for
some control purpose, then the original balance
truncation method cannot be used. And so, under
these conditions, we can for example, decompose
the system into stable and unstable sub systems.
We can use empirical grammarians or a partially
data driven version of balanced truncation which
is called the approximate balance truncation
although these two require adjunct simulations,
so if you don't have access to the address system,
you can use these methods and finally the eigen
system realization algorithm that's the Pew
Really data driven version RBT and if the system
is extremely stiff, then the choice key factors in
the analytical balance truncation method will be
affected can be affected by numerical errors and
the balance rooms can be inaccurate. And in that
case, we would resort to the data driven versions
of balance truncation. Also, if a dimension of the
system is more than a few 1000s, then computing
that grammars with the standard method by solving
the Elliana equations will become expensive, and
we should go with methods two to five. And lastly,
if we don't have access to the internal
description or the governing equations,
or if we want to build a ROM based on the data
that comes from experiments, then eigen system
realization algorithm is pretty much the only
method that we can use here. So, as you can see
era, is a very versatile method that basically
addresses at least all of the limitations
that I have mentioned here. But there is no pre
launch. Like any other data driven methods, the
performance of era roms depends on the training
data that we use for them. So era roms do not
necessarily satisfy the theoretical error bounds
given by by the analytical balance truncation.
And that's why we should be very careful about
the sampling properties when we want to collect
training data for the era ROMs. So now, the I
guess the same realization algorithm is originally
a system identification method that uses the
external description of the system to build a
minimum realization for the for the system,
and it has strong connections with balanced
truncation method, which is why it's considered
a non intrusive data driven version of balanced
truncation. So considering this discrete time
system, which is our full order model, then we
have the Hankel matrix here that we have already
seen before. And why is the sequence of Markov
parameters are the impulse response of the system
and each subsequent row in this Hankel matrix is
constructed by shifting the impulse response
one step forward in time. And despite I've
written this sequence of Markov parameters in
terms of the system matrices, but note that
this is a completely data driven process, and we
don't need access to the full order model matrices
at all. So the next thing that we do is to compute
another matrix, which is called the shifted Hankel
matrix. And this matrix is obtained by shifting
the entire Hankel matrix one step forward in
time. Now, this may remind people of dynamic mode
decomposition, we'll talk about the connections
of era with DMD in the next slide. So then we use
that shifted Hankel matrix along with the singular
values and singular vectors of the Hankel matrix
to build their own matrices. And as you can see,
there are no ABC matrices in these equations,
because the method is non intrusive, and we don't
need access to the full order model matrices or
any adjuncts in simulations unlike the approximate
balance truncation method and therefore, even if
the data comes from experiments, we can still use
this method. Now, for those of you who are
familiar with dynamic mode decomposition,
as shown in this paper, that era is directly
related to the end. So, if we apply DMD to H and
H prime instead of the usual snapshots matrices
A tilde is here, the linear operator given by
DND and if we compare this linear operator
against the dynamics matrix given by era,
we can see that the two matrices are related with
a similarity transform. So, their Eigen values are
the same and their Eigen vectors are related. So
we can as well use era to compute the DMD modes.
Okay, so now, I guess we can see some results
of application of the Eigen system realization
algorithm to our two numerical experiments and
also talk about some practical aspects of our era.
So the first example that we are, we are going
to look at is a one dimensional reacting flow
problem that's governed by the one dimensional
gnabry stokes equations with species transport
and reaction that are shown here. We solve these
equations with a finite volume approach using
the second order row scheme and do all times time
stepping. And in order to solve these equations,
we have used an open source code as developing
our group. This framework is called perform which
stands for prototyping environment for reacting
the order reduction methods, and it's basically a
pack Occasionally, it provides multiple benchmark
problems, including wind emission or reacting
flow problems that can be used to test model
reduction techniques. And it also comes with
multiple model reduction capabilities, including
different projection based model reduction methods
with hyper reduction and linear nonlinear
dimensionality reduction methods. So the
code is available in this GitHub repo, along with
the complete documentation and the capabilities
out there who order model and ROM in the code. So
we saw the nonlinear foot order models subjected
to characteristic boundary conditions. And
this table shows some of the specifics. And
we obtain a steady state solution that's shown
here in these plots which represents a standing
frame in the vicinity of their domain. So this is
pressure, this is velocity, this is temperature,
and this is species mass fraction. And then we
linearize the equations about the steady state
solution together linear setup equations that
we then use to build their era rooms. So this
is our mini article order model here, where j is
the Jacobean matrix evaluated at that city state
solution. And Q is the vector of our primitive
variables, and B contains the boundary fluxes,
u is our input. This plot here shows that Eigen
values have their full order model, all of the
Eigen values are in the left side of them complex
plane. And so the system is stable. Now, what's
challenging about this application is the extreme
stiffness of the system due to the presence of a
chemical source term. So the condition number of
the Jacobean matrix is in the order of 10 to 13,
which as I said, it will introduce numerical
errors in them to address key factors in the
analytical balance truncation. And that's why I
resorted to the data driven version of balance
truncation here, so we train the era wrongs
by by applying unit impulse to the system,
you're applying unit impulse to the backpressure
through the characteristic boundary conditions
at the downstream of the domain, and we collected
snapshots, these thoughts show their normal this
state for pressure, velocity, temperature and
species mass fraction. And as you can see, this
system has a likely damped impulse response, which
means that there is a there's an Eigen vector in
the system that takes a long time to die out.
And that's makes construction of Vi ROMs. More
complex, because we need to capture enough samples
to we need to collect enough samples to capture
the decay of this Eigen vector. And that results
in a larger Hankel matrix that is harder to work
with. So we do that. And then this plot here
shows the singular values, the decay of the
singular values of the Hankel matrix 77, pressure
and velocity minutes 50 temperature and 19 mass
fraction modes capture 99.99% of the input output
energy. So we construct their arms, and this plot
here shows the Eigen values of their arm, all of
them are stable. But note that that time step of
that era ROM is two orders of magnitude larger
than the time step of the full order model. So
if we run the order model, with the same
time step as the ROM, it will be unstable,
which is what these red circles show. And on the
right, we are comparing the reconstruction of
the impulse response by the ROM against the foot
order model, which is perfect match. But we are
more interested in their predictive performance
or roles because at the end of the day, that's
the ultimate goal of model reduction. So we have
trained their arms with unit impulse, and we are
here testing it with a completely different input,
which is the sinusoidal input with a frequency of
215 kilohertz. So ignoring these discrepancies at
the right side for a few seconds, we can see that
in the rest of the domain, the wrong solution
perfectly matches the full order model. Now why
do we have these discrepancies here? Let's look
at these plots on the left which show the impulse
response at an early time step. As you can see, as
the impulse enters the domain from the right side,
there are very sharp gradients close to the
right boundary that attenuate as their impulse
propagates in the domain. And apparently, the
sampling frequency that we use during collection,
our training data for era roms was not sufficient
to capture these sharp gradients and that's why
these discrepancies are here at the right
side of the domain through prediction. But
this is challenging because as as I mentioned, the
system already has a likely dams impulse response,
so we needed to capture a lot of collect a lot of
snaps was to capture that and we cannot afford to
further increase the sampling frequency in the
entire domain to capture those sharp gradients.
And that's why we came up with a simple output
domain decomposition method to resolve these
gradients without the need to increase the
sampling frequency the entire domain. I'll
talk about that later. But before that, we did
some tests to compare the era roms against the
projection based ROMs. Specifically the periodic
collection ROM in this slide, where the purity
modes are trained with the same impulse response
snapshots as the era ROMs and then their arm is
being tested with the same sinusoidal input that
I talked about in the previous slide. So these
plots here show the appropriate measurements for
a probe located at the vicinity of that flame,
the black line is the ROM and that red line is
the full order model. And as you can see, the ROM
is not doing a good job at all in prediction.
And this encouraged us to further compare era
against these squares, Petrov, Galerkin, as well.
So here are the prediction based ROMs are trained
with combined snapshots with perturbations with
frequencies of 200 to 210 and 220 kilohertz,
and then tested with with a with an intermediate
frequency of 215 kilohertz. And these bars show
the relative error computed based on the order
model solution Q and the wrong solution Q hat.
So as you can see, the black line shows the era
wrong, which is the best, and the blue line is
the purity electron. And these three lines
are for the least squares, Petrov, Galerkin,
we have multiple lines because lseg is sensitive
with respect to time step, and we wanted to try
different time steps. So as you can see, none of
these rejection based ROMs are able to compete
against era for this linear system. So let's
return again to the problem that we had at the
right side of the boundary with sharp gradients.
So I said that we didn't want to increase the
sampling frequency in the entire domain, because
that would give us a huge Hankel matrix that's
hard to work with. So we use this output domain
decomposition idea. So consider the description
for order model here. The idea is to decompose
that output matrix output map output matrix C,
into three blocks where each block is used by
a different rom separately. That's why we have
round one, round two and round three. So each
of these roms is trained with impulse response
snapshots collected with a different sampling
frequency. Round one that has the lowest sampling
frequency covers the majority of the computational
domain and run free that has the highest sampling
frequency covers only the five rightmost cells
of the domain, that's where we had the sharpest
gradients. And so although around three has many
more markup parameters compared to round one, but
the number of rows in the Hancock matrix of Round
three is one order smaller than Romblon. And so,
we are basically from moving from the left side
of the domain to the right side of the domain,
we are increasing the sampling frequency while
maintaining computational efficiency as much as
we can. And then we use another method to further
reduce the size of the hand count matrix. This
is called tangential interpolation, which is
developed for multi input multi output systems
to reduce the number of inputs and outputs
before construction of the hand count matrix.
So I've been doing is that we first assemble
the impulse response in two different ways,
as can be seen in theta l n theta r, when we apply
SVD to each of these two matrices separately,
and the singular vectors of theta L are the left
tangential modes w one that represents their
low dimensional output space. And the singular
vectors of theta are, are the rights see rights
tendencia modes of w two that represent the low
dimensional input space. And so what we do is that
we go ahead and project the impulse response onto
these input and output subspaces to get y hat and
use y hat instead, to construct the Hankel matrix
and we follow that same standard procedure for
construction of era ROMs. But at the end, we're
going to need to leave the era raw matrices back
to the original high dimensional input output
space. So we use these methods in our application
and this table shows the offline cost era roms
with and without tangential interpolation,
as as you can see, the tangential interpolation
method has reduced the offline cost by a factor
of around 1.7. And in the online phase, the
online world clock time either era ROM is
is pointing to 116th and which basically gives us
two orders of magnitude reduction in computation
time compared to the world order model. And at the
bottom we have the non predictions for this case
where there is no trace of those discrepancies
at the right out of the domain anymore.
So, next we decided to apply era to a
slightly more complex problem. The goal
here is to use era roms to predict aeroacoustic
response of an airfoil. So, for this example,
we have a subsonic flow and mark points by flow
over an airfoil. And we are prototyping the entire
farfield boundary to model atmospheric turbulence
and then, we are aiming to predict the acoustic
response of the airfoil as the perturbations
propagate and interact in the domain. So,
to that end, we first run the full order the high
fidelity simulations, which are based on the two
dimensional Euler equations here, we use a finite
volume approach with a second order row scheme to
solve the equations subject to characteristic
boundary conditions. So, we generate a steady
state solution, and then we project the equations,
we linearize the equations about that steady state
solution to get a linear set of equations here
that's used to build the era ROMs. Here J is the
Jacobean matrix and Q prime is the perturbation
field. Now, I'd like to mention a few practical
points about application era in this example,
and also in general. So, although theoretically,
we train era roms by the response of the system
to unit impulse, but in practice, depending on
your application, a unit impulse may not even be
physical, or it may not be effective. For example,
in this application, we have a subsonic flow.
And so a unit impulse would mean that we need
to set Mach number along the farfield boundary to
one which is not even consistent with our problem
setup. And on the other hand, we realize that in
this application, applying an impulsive input in
a single time step is not effective. And we
need to apply that input for a longer time to
actually affect affect the system. And so that's
why we decided to perturb the velocity along the
entire farfield boundary with a Gaussian shaped
input. And another point is that as I mentioned,
we need to protect the entire farfield boundary
in this case. So we have a multi input multi
output system, which means that we need to protect
each cell along the pocket boundary to collect a
separate sequence of Markov parameters, and
assemble all of those Markov parameters in
one Hankel matrix and proceed there and proceed
to construction of era roms from there. So for
example, if you have a 400 by 100 grid, we're
going to have 604 cells or input channels along
the parpi boundary for this application. And
therefore, we need to protect each of those
channels, or each of those 604 channels
separately, to collect the training data,
which is apparently very expensive. So as the
grid becomes finer, the number of cells along
the profit boundary increases and the offline cost
of construction of era roms becomes prohibitive.
And that's why we came up with an idea based
on the gappy pod approach to basically reduce
the number of input channels along the path for
field boundary. And therefore the offline costs
of construction of era rounds. We read so many
tests, so you can find the results in this paper,
but in the interest of time, I just directly
jump into the gappy pod idea. So, Gabi pod is
a method that is usually used for sparse sensing
and construction of entire flow fields from sparse
sensor measurements and also for high production
in reduced order models. And the general procedure
for Gabby pod is that we first computer set up
modes for example, purely modes, based on a set
up start training data that are collected
in matrix Q here. So, q can be approximated
by a linear combination of pod mode spy and an ASC
are the modal coefficients. SC is an observation
matrix that basically contains our sparse sensor
measurements. And P is a permutation matrix that
basically identifies the elements chooses the
MN sub q and phi that correspond to the sensor
locations. And the goal here is to reconstruct
the entire flow view from this far set. So
measurements. Now the question is, how do we
know where should we locate those sensors in
order to get maximum reconstruction accuracy? And
that that question is answered in this paper and
also some earlier words. And it's shown in this
paper, that's the optimal location of the sensors
is given by the pivot locations where we apply QR
factorization with column pivoting to the matrix
of pod modes. And this is for the case where the
desired number of sensors is equal to the number
of retained modes. And for the oversampled
case, we should apply QR factorization to
phi phi transpose. And so having the optimal
sensor locations and the sensor measurements
in s and also the pod modes, then we can solve an
inverse problem to obtain the model coefficients.
And from there we can reconstruct the flow field.
And so we have basically adapted this algorithm
for actuator selection. And in our case, our
goal is basically to use this algorithm to
identify the most critical input channels along
the profit boundary, or training the era Ron's.
So the general procedure is very similar to
their standard method. But our training data
is different. Our training data is basically
the Markov sequences corresponding to all of
the input channels that are computed using the
cores a coarse grid. So the whole idea here is
to avoid running the full order model in the high
resolution grid to obtain that Markov sequences
for all of the input channels. So we instead run
the full order model in a coarser grid and collect
the training data for gappy pod. And this table
compares the dimensions of these matrices in our
implementation of the method against the standard
Gephi pod method. And so Q that contains our
training data here is p by n, where p is the total
number of actual leaders, and m is the number of
snapshots as the observation matrix is p, which is
actually not the observation matrix. But PS by m,
where p is is the desired number of actuators
and p is their permutation matrix, it's Psy p
and a hat is similar to the standard approach.
So let me take this algorithm and reconstruct
the Markov sequence of a note that we are not
using the reconstruction of Markov sequence by
Gabby purity at all. Here, the only thing that we
need from this algorithm is the location of the
most critical input channels along the far field
boundary that we want to use in order to train
in order to perturb only those channels in the
full order model that is run in the final grade.
So we use this method for our 400 by 100 grid,
where we have a total of 604 input channels along
the powerful boundary and gappy pod gives the
optimal location for 150 input channels. That's
the only part of those channels to collect Markov
sequences to train the era roms then we also use
a tangential interpolation to further reduce
the size of the Hankel matrix. And this table
shows the number of retained left and right
tangential nodes and also their arm dimension.
Note that their left modes represent a reduction
from 40,000 output channels and the right modes
represented reduction from 100 and originally 600
150 And originally 604 input channels, so that
reduction is major. And the left plot here shows
the decay of singular values of the Hankel matrix
and the lower right plot shows the Eigen values of
the era roms that are stable. So now, we'd like to
evaluate the predictive performance of the ROMs
by trying different types of inputs that are not
seen during the training. So, we have trained the
era roms by the Gaussian shaped input and here we
are using the sinusoidal input in perturbing
velocity along at all 604 channels along the
forward boundary simultaneously. And these parts
here show their probe measurements or probe that
is located at the bottom of the airfoil. So,
besides some discrepancies in the amplitude of
the v components of velocity, we can see that
the ROM agrees very well with the full order
model. And this is also shown in these in this
snapshot of the pressure perturbation control,
where the left one is the full order model and
the right one is the ROM. So we decided to test
more complex input signal which is this triangle
wave with sharp radians and a I'm looking at the
probe measurements, there are some discrepancies
in the new components of velocity. But overall,
their arms are correctly picking up the dynamics
in response to a more challenging input channel
as well. And the last input signal that we tried
was a non periodic step input that we apply to the
entire profit boundary all 604 channels, not only
the channels identified by GAAP up already, and
again, we can still see that they're wrong, is
replicating the dynamics and dynamics of the order
model very well. So that's where the accuracy of
the reduced order models regarding computational
savings, this table gives us some information
about the online and offline computational
savings, the linear linearization of the order
model gave us an order of magnitude reduction in
computation time for each Markov sequence,
the low fidelity gap up with the approach,
reduce the number of input channels by a factor
of four, and therefore the computation time of the
training data by 353 hours. And unfortunately, we
were not able to compute an online offline speed
factor because without the Gabi pod method,
constructing the era roms was beyond our
computational resources. And at the in the online
phase, the era rom gave us a speed up factor of
258. And so we went through a long journey in the
past 15 minutes, almost 15 minutes. The takeaway
message messages are that I guess it's gonna
be a violation algorithm is a non intrusive,
data driven version of balanced truncation
that addresses many of the limitations of
this method in application to more complex
problems. Although the downside is that,
like any other data driven method, the performance
of era roms depends on the training data. And so
we should be careful about the sampling properties
to train era ROMs. But if if trained properly era
roms can operate in a purely predicting predictive
scenario. And looking at the applications,
we also said that sampling the impulse response
sufficiently could be challenging, because it may
increase the upfront cost of construction
of era ROMs. For example, when the system
has a lightly damped impulse response, or sharp
gradients that need higher sampling frequencies,
and also in systems with many inputs and
input and output channels, also, the cost
of era increases. And then we introduced some
additional methods to reduce the offline cost,
like the tangential interpolation method, domain
decomposition approach, and also a low fidelity
version of the gappy pod method for actuator
selection. And lastly, there are topics that could
be pursued further, as as future work will be, for
example, application era to larger scale problems
and coming up with ideas to further decrease the
offline custom era ROMs and also improving upon
the existing algorithms for era in time varying
and nonlinear systems, which is also something
that we are currently working on. And with that,
I'd like to open the floor for any questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the wonderful
talk. Very informal talker, and I learned a lot
about the balance truncation. Great. Yes, let's,
let's have a q&a session. I can start, I have
clarification person if you go to slide 35 If you
don't mind. 30. Yeah. And you compare the LSP 10.
color scheme. Okay, pod there. You apply the LSP
and Galerkin to legalized pool the motor Moodle?
Yes, that's correct. Yes. Okay, cool, because
they can be applied to nonlinear? Yes,
of course. Yeah. But we wanted
them to be consistent with the
era round. So we applied them to the
linearized pull order modeling. So
and when the conclusion like that story,
you you're telling in this slide is
when it when it is applied to the
linear problem? Yeah, they can outperform in
terms of accuracy, both lsphp and consulte.
Yes, so CCRA is basically that data
driven version of balance truncation,
it's able to perform in a purely predictive
setting where the input signal is not seen
during that training in the training data,
why the projection based ROMs are not able to
perform as well as era in such a truly predictive
setting without having observed that perturbation.
Well, there are there are ways of parameterizing
the A call akin pod and LSPD.
Sure you have all tied those
back? No, no, we are here using the standard
prediction based model reduction methods.
So we are basically comparing the
era to the standard methods. Okay,
that variant, the parametric. Alright. We do
have a question in chat room, Kevin asked. Okay,
he has a few questions for future milestones
first, what would your approach be toward
unsteady nonlinear problem? And second
question is how can it be extended toward
a more generic input than a linear actuator?
So he basically has a two questions. Right.
So for linear problems, for
nonlinear problems, and I mean,
that's the million dollar question. Although
there have been some efforts. Like for example,
for weakly nonlinear problems, some people
directly apply the same balance truncation
algorithm. And also there have been
some recent efforts using again,
methods that stem from the approximate balance
truncation mainly using covariance balancing,
for example, but I haven't seen any methods
that apply era rounds to nonlinear problems,
it has been in the same direction as approximate
balance truncation, but not the, I guess, the same
realization algorithm, because they are different.
You know, because approximate balance Truncation
is kind of partially data driven, we still
need access to the broader model operators
and I joined system simulations, but balance
location is about era is purely data driven.
And the question was, how can it be extended for
the more generic input than a linear actuator?
Well, at least for the problems that we have
considered here, and any type of input that
we have used, works on these problems. So
I think, if the ROMs are trained properly,
any type of input that you use would
be would result in accurate rounds.
Thank you. And that's, um, I have questions about
the gappy pod that, that you introduced. And I
don't know if it's like 4243 or something like
that. When I heard that, first, I thought to you,
you use the KP pod to reduce the Amira
dimensionality cost, as you you know,
refine the mesh on the boundary, the number
of parameter increases crazy and the high
dimensional parameter space, it's, it's really
hard to deal with in the data driven approach in
general. So you try to use the dimensionality of
the permanent space on campus using a pod. There
was what I my understanding, but up to in this
slide here, you're doing something different,
I mean, you apply, you run the
simulation course agreed. And then
yeah, so we are running the simulations over
the coarser grid to collect the training
data for gappy pod. And then we are using the
optimal actuator location locations given by
the pivots of a QR factorization with Colin
pivoting in the iPod to identify the most
critical input channels, which means their input
channels that affect the Markov sequence the most.
Okay, great, I guess my understanding what
some are correct, then how many how many,
you know, indices do you extract Okay, pod is
Yeah, so, we are so, p is here is the desired
number of actuator locations, we have considered
150 input channels. So, we are reducing from the
original 604 input channels to 150 input channels.
I see. Okay. So, that definitely helps on the
Yes. So, as as I said, this basically reduces the
cost of construction duration of
the training data by 353 hours.
Okay. All right. Sounds good. Okay, any
other questions from audience? You can
unmute yourself and ask questions. To be shy
Um, well, if not, let's thank our speaker
today elnaz for the wonderful talk, and it
was very informal talk, and I learned a lot
from you, so much texture and everyone has
a great speaker. Well, that's, you know,
concludes the today's seminar. Let's thank
our speaker. That's one more time. And I think
the next TDPs seminar is Tuesday next week,
which will be a hybrid. So if you're on
site, and you can actually come in person,
so I hope to see you there. All
right. Thank you. Nice. Thanks.